[Music]
a second wave of covert 19 hit india
hard
but case numbers look like they're
falling restrictions are easing
so is india ready shops businesses and
public transport are opening in delhi
people in mumbai can catch a movie at
the cinema
still the country's vaccination drive is
sluggish and testing isn't
widespread experts warn case numbers and
deaths are being
under reported they say it's too soon to
lift restrictions
welcome i'm ben fazoulen after almost
two months locked down in delhi the
construction sector
is one of the first to reopen it relies
largely on migrant laborers who've been
returning to the big city from their
villages
in the hope of finding work dw's manira
chowdhury sent us this report
daily wage labourers gather here every
morning to find work
32 year old yogesh kohli is one of them
he is an unskilled migrant labourer who
has been working in the informal
sector in the capital for almost six
years
but times are tough for him he was left
without any work when delhi went into
lockdown after the city was hit
by the second wave of covet
we're barely getting any work there is
so much unemployment
many other laborers have also come back
from the villages they wait you for a
job
every day but there just isn't enough
work
yogesh says he finds casual work only
one or two days a week
hardly enough to make a living
economist prabhakar singh says the
problem is much bigger
he says that many migrant workers are
choosing not to come back
at all and are dropping out of the
workforce because they see few
opportunities of finding employment
and he thinks any recovery will take
time
it's not the virus cycle which
determines the economic cycle
you know it is basically the the larger
effect of the first wave is still
lingering on
and it will compound with this second
surge and it will
possibly get into a bigger effect or it
will take a
longer time for the economy to for the
labor market to
for the employment rates to come to the
nominal or normal terms
yogesh the unskilled worker remembers
how last year millions were left
jobless during the national lockdown
some of them never found work again he
fears that the same may happen to him
i'm thinking that if i don't get work
soon i'll go back to my village
and it looks like i might have too there
seems to be no work right now
it was another day with no job for
yogesh
he will be back again at the same spot
tomorrow morning waiting for work
but he doesn't know how much longer he
can hold out
so here we are again talking about lives
and livelihoods whether or not to open
or reopen
with rajiv descriptor chairperson of the
centre of social medicine and community
health at jnu in delhi
last time we spoke a couple of months
ago the situation was dire
thousands were dying every day hospitals
were close to collapse
they'd run out of oxygen how are things
now
hello ben good evening from new delhi uh
last time we spoke yes it was dire
straits
uh this time of course uh people have
heaped a sigh of relief notwithstanding
the losses
each family has gone through uh
things certainly are a lot better now
particularly in
most of the high incident states
economy different sectors of the economy
as you said are opening up
and the challenge before
politicians as well as administrators is
how to balance the needs of lives and
livelihoods
i think the key challenge at this point
is maintaining
uh the the the covet preparedness but
also making workplaces safer from the
corvette point of view
you um sound quite optimistic
in your judgment of the situation but
the death toll was only
spiking again just a few days ago i mean
we had the highest
numbers reported so far just last week
well the death toll has certainly been
high
as i said it's been very painful for
almost each and every family
last week the death figures
uh are to be understood in the context
that several
states actually reviewed and audited
their death figures sometimes
under directions from their respective
high courts
and therefore some of these corrections
have actually taken place it's not that
the absolute number of deaths
in the preceding week has been that high
uh and yes therefore
the debts that we have ended up with are
certainly higher than it seemed
and and some more states are going
through this correction or audit process
and the tally could actually be a little
higher than even what it seems now
well the health department in bihar one
of india's poorest states revised its
total covert related death toll from
some five and a half thousand two over
nine and a half
thousand on wednesday last week what's
going on is this
down to under reporting in some places
there is certainly an element of under
reporting
this is not necessarily to to indicate
that
that this has been deliberate but uh
it's part of the system coping up uh
there is
also uh the who advisory issued last
year as early as april 2020
as to what counts as a corporate death
and
uh it seems that the clarity of that
document of
of those definitions and and certainly
some of the
subtexts of those definitions uh perhaps
uh
didn't didn't really didn't really tell
you with what
what health departments were actually
doing and therefore as in the case of
bihar the high court of bihar
actually uh asked for this audit or
review process
and it's a and then this this this
change or the uptick in the figures is
really a culmination of that
what about this highly infectious delta
variant if i if i can butt in there
well the delta variant which is actually
the
sub lineage of v6171
was identified in india earlier this
year
in the southeastern districts of
the very last state of maharashtra it's
it's now subsequently
swept through through several large
states including delhi
delhi actually has been uh has been
affected both by the alpha variant as
well as by the delta variant
and and therefore a lot of what we
witnessed in the second surge in india
uh does does owe a lot to the
to the damage caused by the delta
variant
uh and and therefore india has now gone
through this
uh variant largely we have gained in
that experience
uh states have popped up coped with
uh with this surge in in various manners
and we we certainly see uh
the delta variant led subsiding in most
states including delhi mumbai as the
earlier report indicated
and therefore therefore life is
certainly limping back to normalcy you
mentioned before the businesses
uh are not um giving enough attention to
preventing the spread of covert 19 in
the workplaces
the economy reopens is is india on top
of this is the country taking the right
steps
i believe making workplaces safer and by
this workplace i do not just mean office
spaces but
but in fact all works of economy where
people
are working in indoor environments uh
that's something which
we really need to focus a lot more
beyond
uh the usual the platitudes of
maintaining distance etc
because in in real life situations uh
workplaces not just in india this is
true of of of many countries in the
world
aside from those who actually have the
option of working from home
those who actually need to be physical
in workspaces
uh do face a lot of risk anecdotally
these are the people
who have suffered much of the brunt in
the second wave
and and therefore we really need to do a
lot more on making
workplaces safer just going beyond
washing hands and so on because
the structural issues of the buildings
the rooms the ventilation
uh the air conditioning systems wherever
they are
available these certainly need a lot
more attention and details
okay you heard it from rajiv desculta
from the center of social medicine and
community health thank you
thank you ben well we talked about it
before for several weeks it was referred
to as the indian
variant i know if i were indian i'd take
offense it
also has a long complicated lineage
category but now it's called
delta more on that with derek williams
and this viewer question
is the b1617 variant more deadly
as well as more contagious
this variant of concern which has been
designated
delta under a new naming system
recommended by the who
it was first identified several months
ago in
india and it has subsequently been found
in many other parts of the world
although final proof is still missing
there's significant evidence that b16172
or delta is a lot more transmissible
than the original version of the virus
and and even
more contagious than the the alpha
variant that hit
some countries hard last winter in
particular britain
their delta is now causing fresh concern
after the country planned to leave
lockdowns behind
on on june 21st delta is estimated
to be causing around nine in ten cases
in a new surge in the uk we're still
flying blind in many places when it
comes to tracking the spread
of specific variants and tying them for
instance to to hospitalizations
that makes it hard to currently say with
any certainty
whether the delta variant causes more
severe disease
but the evidence is mounting that it
possibly does
britain's responsible agency said that
its early data
indicated that people who got the delta
variant
were more than two and a half times more
likely to end up hospitalized
than those who had contracted the alpha
variant
and and chinese officials according to
the new york times
have also said more patients in a new
outbreak linked to the delta variant
there
are showing up at hospitals more
severely or critically ill
so so evidence would appear to be
mounting
that the delta variant is indeed more
dangerous
especially to people who haven't
received at least
one dose of vaccine but healthcare
authorities and many scientists
don't think the evidence is robust
enough yet
to make an unequivocal case
[Music]